mercredi 18 octobre 2023 une révélation
inquiétante fait la Une le Canard
Enchaîné publie un mail confidentiel du
directeur de l'agence régionale de santé
d'ooccitani l'intéressé y évoque la
présence de polluants éternels et de
pesticides dans l'eau de la région et
affirme que celle-ci ne doit plus être
consommée le directeur de la RS
Occitanie réagit quelques jours plus
tard dans un autre journal il s'agissait
d'un mail interne n'ayant aucune valeur
d'information qui reprenait une prise de
note personnelle et succès et qui
forcément sortie de son contexte a pu
faire naître une inquiétude alors y
a-t-il de quoi s'inquiéter boire l'eau
du robinet est-il
dangereux selon le ministère de la santé
et de la prévention l'udio robinet est
l'aliment le plus contrôlé en France sa
surveillance est exercée par la personne
responsable de la production et de la
distribution de l'eau et son contrôle
sanitaire piloté par les agences
régionales de santé c'est un contrôle
qui se fait au niveau régional donc si
il est pas uniforme au niveau national
les contrôles V être spécifiques dans
chaque région en fonction des des usages
qui qu'il y a notamment agricole dans
dans les régions les ARS vont adapter
leur contrôle il y a quand même des
choses qui sont obligatoirement à
contrôler qui sont dites dans une
directive européenne que la France
applique par contre il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont pas encore à rechercher
obligatoirement fin octobre selon les
dernières données publiques de l'ARS
plusieurs départements ne répondent pas
aux exigences de qualité par exemple
concarne en mont Agne pour concentration
excessive en chlore ou encore châteler
sur Meuse dans le Grand Est qui présente
une forte teneur en ammonium aujourd'hui
que donnent ces contrôles est-ce
habituel que la qualité de l'eau du
robinet ne soit pas validée par l'agence
régionale de santé ça peut arriver
heinuellement il y a des exemples par
exemple quand suite à de très fortes
pluies quand la nappe d'eau est
contaminée alors c'est souvent des
contaminants biologiques puisque c'est
ceux qui sont à toxicité immédiate donc
des micro-organismes par exemple des
bactéries des virus ça peut arriver que
les les contrôles fassent que l'eau est
dite impropre à la consommation non ce
n'est pas fréquent de ne pas répondre
aux exigences de qualité trois chiffres
pour la microbiologie on a
98 % de la population qui est alimentée
en permanence par une eau conforme pour
les pesticides presque 83 % de la
population et puis pour les nitrates on
est à plus de 90 9 % de la population
qui est alimentée en permanence par une
eau conforme juste sur le paramètre
pesticide chaque année le ministère de
de la Santé publie les résultats de
nonconformité les pourcentages de
conformité de noncformité qu'il y a eu
au cours de l'année donc là en 2021 donc
c'est les derniers résultats qui sont
disponibles il y avait 15 % des unités
de distribution qui étaient non
conformes juste sur le paramètrre
pesticide ça concernait quand même 11
millions d'habitants parmi ces molécules
dont la recherche n'est pas obligatoire
les polluants éternels qu'on appelle
aussi piface ou perfloré une famille de
composés chimiques fabriqué par l'homme
qui est compliqué dans les P c'est que
c'est une famille qui comprend autour de
4000 composés différents qui sont des
molécules qui contiennent des atomes de
fluor et qui ont des propriétés
antiadhésives imperméabilisantes ils ont
beaucoup été utilisé notamment dans
l'industrie textille qui résistent très
bien des fortes chaleurs et donc c'est
des composés qui sont utilisés de façon
sont massives dans l'industrie depuis à
peu près la fin des années 50 les pifas
sont très résistants dans
l'environnement d'où leur nom de
polluant éternels outre leur impact
environnemental ils auraient également
des conséquences sur notre santé il y a
des effets des effets sur la santé qui
ont été retrouvés dans énormément de de
publications ça va des effets des
troubles du métabolisme des effets
cancérigènes des effets sur la
reproduction des effets sur le système
immunitaire ce sont c'est les effets sur
le système immunitaire qu'on va
retrouver au plus FA faible dose donc au
plus faible dose on parle de l'ordre du
du nanogramme par litre ces substances
peuvent avoir des effets premier effet
qui est retrouvé c'est une diminution de
l'efficacité de certains vaccins d'ici
2026 selon une directive européenne un
renforcement des mesure de contrôle de
ces substances présentes dans l'eau
potable est attendue certains
territoires sont déjà concernés par de
telles mesures comme la région lyonnaise
pourquoi renforcer ces contrôles
aujourd'hui sont-ils assez efficaces la
norme la réglementation c'est les
pouvoirs publics et les autorités
sanitaires qui les mettent en place avec
avec des experts qui sont là pour dire
si la norme est suffisante ou pas moi ce
que je peux dire en règle générale pour
les normes de qualité pour la qualité de
de l'eau elles sont toujours prises de
manière hyper prudente c'est-à-dire
qu'on se donne des marges de sécurité
importantes justement par rapport au
risque qui existe on recherche c'est
perfluoré que dans les endroit où la
pollution est déjà avérée mais on sait
que cette pollution au per fluoré elle
est complètement diffuse et généralisé
sur tout le territoire donc là a
énormément d'endroits pour lesquels on
recherche pas encore il y a aussi la
question des métabolites de pesticides
où on en recherche très peu alors qu'on
sait que il y en a beaucoup qui risquent
de migrer vers les eaux souterraines et
se retrouver plus tard dans l'eau
potable donc clairement la la recherche
de qualité de ces micropolluants dans
l'eau potable est totalement insu
[Musique]
suffante